protests in Iran are gaining momentum
LED initially by women and girls crying
woman life liberty after the death of a
young Kurdish woman detained for wearing
her headscarf inappropriately the
uprising is now drawing thousands of
others onto the streets the protesters
chat death to the dictator calling for
the end of the repressive clerical
regime which is hitting back hard its
Violet Crackdown has killed or detained
hundreds of civilians journalists and
activists and shut down the internet
today we are asking Iran Rises up can
the mules be toppled
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
and it is a pleasure to greet our guests
Gilda sahibi is an author and journalist
of Iranian origin who writes among other
Publications for the German daily the
tots
is the head of the Farsi desk here at
Deutsche Villa we're very pleased to
welcome her as a colleague and Daniel
Dylan Burma who reports on Iran for the
berlin-based daily devout also joins us
and guilt if I can start with you it is
of course uh not only women but also
school girls who are now tearing off
their hijabs in public their head
scarves uh are now becoming a symbol for
defiance of the regime where is this
Fury coming from have you been surprised
by its Force
I must say I have actually I mean we've
have this protest for three weeks now
roughly and when they started I thought
well it is new a lot of it is still new
women and men going together
chanting as you said women life Freedom
which is new because all genders go are
together they're fighting for for
women's right together and human rights
but now it's the Gen Z is rising up as
well we see gen Z rising up all over the
world and now we see the neuron and the
force and the courage of these girls
these young girls who know the hierarchy
of this oppressive regime in schools
we've seen schoolgirls like shouting out
the director of the school of this it's
it's just scenes that I am surprised by
because the of the force the power of
them and the other this of course is not
the first protest in Iran in the past
decade but it is unique in that it was
led initially by women and girls do you
think that will make a difference to its
outcome
I definitely think it will and what we
can see already is that these protests
um have a different dimension a
different quality than all the other
protests in the recent years but we have
to say Iran has seen we have business a
lot of wave of protests in the last 40
years but it was more like every 10
years and then we can we could witness
that how these uh how it became every
year so we had 2017-2018 big Pro huge
protest then we have 2019 which was more
of course I forgot to mention 2009 which
was the green movement which is very
important but then the difference was it
was more about reformers or or hotliners
it was about more freedom it was the the
students the elite more or less not
asking for a regime change or this
change of the system of Islamic Republic
indeed they're now shouting death to
them now exactly no we don't hear the
slogans about reformers or or
hardliners what we hear is this to
dictator and addressing the supreme
leader
Ayatollah Khomeini and for because of
this the role of the women in here being
on the Forefront on this protest this is
really gaining a different dimension and
they are really addressing one of the
symbols of the Islamic Republic they are
challenging
um they hijab the first hijab for women
so Daniel as we've heard the the
protests have been gaining momentum uh
many many students now joining the
protests but also facing a very violent
Crackdown do you think that the
protesters can maintain their opposition
their Defiance in the face of violence I
think it will be a struggle it will be a
very hard struggle we will likely see
this going on for months and um if you
look at the details of what's happening
in individual cities you see that the
level of violence is is rising and that
the government of Iran has basically
told its population that everybody
taking part in these demonstrations
faces the risk of death and um this is
definitely a new situation and I think
it will be hard to maintain this level
of protests but I think what's sure is
that Iran will not remain the same after
this kind of protests no matter if this
system can be toppled now or not and we
want to drill a bit deeper into
precisely that as the protests proved to
be more than a temporary Outburst the
regime has moved to shut down internet
access blocking social media platforms
that's made it harder for the victims of
official brutality to document it and
still some images of police firing live
ammunition at crowds and beating
civilians who are unarmed are getting
through and arousing widespread
revulsion
women life Freedom has become their
rallying cry thousands of Iranians have
taken to the streets Nationwide since
mid-september fueled by rage and grief
over the presumably violent death of
Gina Masa amini
the morality police arrested and
detained the 22 year old woman for
allegedly wearing her hijab incorrectly
what exactly happened next is unclear
but amini fell into a coma and died
shortly afterwards in a hospital
women are setting fire to their
headscarves and shouting we are fighting
we are dying and we will take back Iran
many men have also joined the growing
demonstrations against the oppressive
government its security forces and the
Islamic regime
but retaliation has been brutal
at least 130 people are said to have
been killed to date
solidarity have been pouring in from
around the world while the Iranian
government's violent response to the
demonstrations has been heavily
criticized by the U.S Europe and even
some Middle Eastern countries like
Lebanon
will the protests topple the mula's
regime
and Gilda let me put that central
question straight away to you how
dangerous is this for the regime I think
it's very dangerous I think what Daniel
said
whatever happens this flame that we have
been seeing on the streets in in all
over the country it won't go out it
won't go away and we see the young girls
they have seen they have felt you cannot
underestimate the importance of emotions
here they have felt they have
experienced Freedom they've taken off
their hijab they have danced on the
streets they have sang on the streets
they they felt it all they experienced
it all and it is true that the regime is
cracking down very very hard on everyone
whatever wherever they see something
we've seen videos of security forces
just shooting randomly on the streets
like things that that's just
unimaginable for us here and even if
they do end at some point which we don't
even know I think also that it might
just go on for weeks or months
this is not going to go away and I
believe that the resistance that we've
been seeing now is gonna get more
structural and organized I don't think
they're just gonna leave it at what it
is right now very interesting I'm going
to come back to that point in in just a
moment but but looking at the causes of
this uh yalda how much of this is about
the tragic death of Masa amini whom we
saw in the report and how much of it is
about a whole pile of additional
indignities
it is both
um actually we have to see that people
are fed up people are
um especially women 50 of the population
that have basically lost all their
rights in the last 40 years since since
the Islamic Republic uh was founded so
um and and then we have economic uh
issues we have human rights there is
that do not exist basically so what we
what the difference is here with the
tragic and brutal death of Masa Gina
Masa amini this is something that
everyone can rely
she is a symbol for this protest we we
did have symbols for protests but not a
symbol that everyone can relate every
woman like every woman in Iran growing
up you get to experience the morality
police you get this brutal humiliating
experience experience and violence
through morality police because of not
being able to wear or to dress the way
you want to because of a little bit of
hair that is the thing is she was not
even without a hijab or without the the
headscarf she had it just not properly
not probably put on as they as they put
it so there's many many Iranian women do
exactly and I have to say when we see uh
40 years ago how it started and there
were women taking to the streets and
protesting against the forced hijab but
then they with the repression and they
had to kind of accept it but what we see
now and you know the headscarves getting
looser cetera this is an achievement of
the women in the last four decades but
what I want to say is of course now this
is so many more this is about so many
more and so many I think it's very
powerful to see how men supporting women
on the streets how the Young Generation
especially took uh is taking and another
dimension or another factor factor is I
think Gilda also I mentioned it school
school girls school students so we have
one one aspect is the students
University students because in the last
protest it was said that the student
movement is dead they are back and they
will organize themselves and this will
go on even if it's thin it will not go
on on the streets if they will really
crack on crack down on protesters this
will go on and universities people will
organize which of course we just have
have seen uh Daniel as I said the
internet has been shut down social media
sites are blocked so how much do we
really know about the breadth of this
movement protesters themselves say it
has become a Revolt uh would you also
use that term to describe it
I think it's fair to say that it is a
Revolt because it's so broad we don't
know the exact size if you look at the
various human rights organizations and
opposition groups they are hand out
figures that differ widely what we know
is uh that it's taking place uh in
definitely more than 100 cities and
places so uh geography or do we know
anything about what's happening in the
countryside well we know that it is
going into the provinces that have been
some reports also about action in
villages but what we know more about is
what's going on in the city so the the
scope of this is very big and I think
what's most noteworthy is that the kind
of people taking place is very very
Broad and I think this is what makes the
crucial difference here the last
protests like the fuel protests in
2019-20 they were more focused on the
poorer classes the 2009 protests against
the likely fake election in 2009 was
carried by the middle classes to a large
degree now we have everybody on the
street and the interesting thing is that
this was possible because it focused on
women because this experience of
marginalization of women is something
that every family in Iran knows no
matter where it's placed on the social
stratum and I think this has surprised
us also because basically everybody
thought well Iran in the end it's a
macho Middle Eastern society and it's
not that simple and also about the
cities yeah because 70 of the population
do live in cities so it's not even if
you don't know exactly what's going on
in the on the country side and the
provinces most people do live in the
cities so and can I just ask you uh
guilty because we heard the religious
leader of Iran the Ayatollah uh that was
a pleasure recently blaming the violence
the protests on reron's usual scapegoats
the U.S and Israel and she was looking
pretty confident when he spoke to the
public do you think he will get buy-in
for that narrative
well he's had practice for decades like
what we've been seeing is what it was to
be expected I mean he did hold back for
quite a while they were like I mean
there have been rumors about him being
sick for a long time everyone's like is
he sick is he not sick everyone believes
it and what we saw was just the same
thing over and over again and what I
believe is that this was directed not at
the people because people in Iran they
know that they're lying there's no doubt
about it when you ask when you talk to
people in Iran everyone knows that
they're lying to them all the time
but when when but this is directed
especially to the to to the West like we
have it under control we have it's you
know we do what we always do we're gonna
bring this down and Israel and the US
are to blame that's a that's a play and
the game that we've been seeing over and
over but still
things are not changing that's the
difference this time yeah I knew you
were looking slightly skeptical there
yeah I I'm not sure that everybody knows
they're lying I'm not sure that all the
population is against the regime I do
think that there is of course I'm I
don't mean that I don't think that you
meant to imply that I just think that
it's also important to keep in mind that
there's a there is a hardcore
um around the regime which is bigger
than the hardcore around most regimes
around the world there is a a
um a popular movement of the besiege
around the regime uh whose size is
depending on the way you count it
between uh a million people and maybe 12
million people
um who both depend on that regime
economically and who are also mentally
and psychologically deeply deeply rooted
in this and they do feel under attack
there have been feeling under attack
since the 80s and they see this as a
continuation so one of the scenarios
that we should be looking at is not only
a violent regime Crackdown but also a
kind of a civil war that might break out
because there is others another side
yeah the one I
it is right it is correct was then what
Daniel is is pointing to but we have to
see that um this hardcore and what you
you named it also the revolution
revolutionary guard copes the basiji's
these they are of course they will die
yeah and you know give
die for for to keep up the ideology of
the regime to keep up the Islamic to
hold uh you know to hold on to the
Islamic Republic and its ideology but
there are less and less normal people
normal as to say even religious people
who had maybe 40 years ago 43 years ago
supported the Islamic Republic and their
fellows even those we know that they
have turned their back on on this this
way of ruling and this uh interpretation
of the Islam by the uh by the by the
clerics so so I think we have to of
course they will be Crackdown and they
are in power and the Russian guard Corps
have economic power it's it's you know
they they task is to defend the enemy in
side and outside of the country but I
still think that what we can see on the
streets now also is that this is
different layers of society United
standing United and let me let me
briefly ask about that if I may I want
to quickly uh move on to ask what the
West Canon should do but first getting
back to your remarks that you've made
about the fact that you think the
protests can endure and you think you
see clear clear leadership or that the
potential for Clear leadership I believe
you said that and also uh Daniel I
wouldn't say leadership organization
organization normally we say that for
protests to really become something like
a regime changing event it requires not
only leadership but also Security
Services or some part of the government
to switch sides who amongst you sees
that likelihood
there are signs already we've seen
videos on social media of
uh people even from the normal army or
also uh the artists I'm not sure I don't
I think don't think they were
revolutionary guard people but still
normal army army who said stop killing
Iranians like they've posted videos
online and and that's the first time
we're seeing that
um I don't think there will be
leadership I'm not sure Iranians like
leaders like one leader and also the
regime would remove them immediately
that wouldn't work it's it has to be
brought it has to be something that all
people carry together and that's what
we're seeing okay sorry I'm going to
make a cut there because I do want to
talk about how other countries can and
should respond and in many European
countries Iran's ambassadors have been
summoned to account for the regime's
Crackdown the U.S has imposed new
sanctions on Iran the EU is threatening
to do the same but would they make a
difference
[Music]
on May 8 2018 former U.S president
Donald Trump signed a document that
annulled the Iran nuclear deal
negotiated by the Obama Administration
three years prior
much safer thank you very much
deal was replaced by a policy that
maximized political pressure and imposed
an even tougher embargo
affecting virtually every sphere of life
and no Iranian has been spared
the sanctions are very tyrannical this
is a tyranny against the people of Iran
it is important to us to have the
sanctions lifted
but negotiations with Iran for a new
deal are slow to progress and the mula's
regime doesn't seem to be in any rush to
comply
meanwhile there are reports of Iran
expanding its uranium enrichment program
meaning the country is closer than ever
to having nuclear capabilities
why won't Iran concede on the nuclear
issue
and let me put that question straight to
Daniel you know just a couple of months
ago it looked like the nuclear agreement
could be revived now it seems to be dead
in the water once again why is that and
what does the standstill mean for
Western leverage vis-a-vis Iran I think
we should be really really worried about
the state of the nuclear talks because
if you talk to the negotiators to the
people who have been sitting on the
table on the negotiating table with the
Iranians for years even those who have
defended this process and this attempt
to reintegrate Iran
are now in doubt whether Iran at all
wants a deal and the reason is that they
have progressed with a nuclear program
so strongly and is in such a clear
military Direction this is so clearly
now a program which is directed at
acquiring at least nuclear weapons
capability and they're now
obstructing the negotiation stations by
opening up questions that had been
negotiated before
so the doubts are very big here and I
think the connection to the um to the
unrest in Iran is that of course
preserving the regime that's the first
priority which the Iranian leadership
regards both in the nuclear talks and in
internal policy and I think that this
unrest will accelerate the decision of
the regime either to go for nuclear
weapons or nuclear weapons capability or
a change of course what we are not what
we have not been seeing in the last few
years is that the likelihood for
changing course has grown has actually
diminished there's a radicalization but
let's remember the thing that brought
Iran to the negotiating table back in
2014 and 2015 was sanctions
additional sanctions would they actually
hurt the regime which has a record of
corruption and economic mismanagement or
would they hurt the Iranian people
the thing is we need more pressure on
Iran the West the EU needs another Iran
strategy the worst thing to do now is to
get back to the to the nuclear deal as
if nothing had happened and go this is
this this is a really bad signal for the
people in Iran because as you know
sanctions of course they hurt people but
on the other hand do you we didn't hear
any slogans on the streets
um saying please lift lift the sanctions
because people know even if you lift the
sanctions it's not the people who will
profit from that it it will basically
make no change so it is important to put
it depends on what kind of sanctions
um
um there was there was we're talking
about you know sanctions on persons on
on persons responsible for the Crackdown
for killing their own people but
responsible is uh in the end the supreme
leader Ayatollah for for all this so um
I think it is symbolic this kind of
sanctions it is good but it's not enough
in a word briefly what would you want
the EU to do what does that new strategy
look like hold Iran accountable for what
is happening in in the country right now
and another aspect is very briefly for
the people in Iran it's very important
to see support what in one dimension is
you know artists celebrities people
speaking out people you know
solidarizing with the people in Iran
cutting their hairs we had the French
actresses Juliet binach and some others
cutting their hairs this is strong
people see that but what we need now we
cannot leave them alone because what is
happening is the internet shut down we
had it 2019 they will just go on and
kill and arrest we have arrested I I had
a quote from one protester that I saw
When I Was preparing for this show who
said the regime is trying to turn Iran
into North Korea nuclear armed and
completely isolated is that a real risk
I don't think they will be completely
isolated I think Russia and China are
happy to jump in so I think it's
important for the West like we heard
from the German foreign minister on
Monday she said she's she's she showed
like compassion and and she acknowledged
the fight of the people and she said
it's too bad we can't really do much but
that's not true like there's a whole
range of things that can be done in in
foreign policies there you can freeze
assets you can stop children and
families of these regime people from
traveling all over the world like
spending all the money that they've
taken from the people targeted sanctions
targeted sanctions and that wouldn't
hurt the people because as the other
says like they know that they're not
getting any of this any of the money
that's coming in so I don't I'm not sure
if they can turn Iran into North Korea
because there's just too much connection
to other to the rest of the world we
have families all over the place people
are connected
yeah let me ask Daniel briefly let's
come back to the title Iran Rises up can
them Willis be toppled
nothing lasts forever that's for sure
so you'd say yes it's possible but uh
the question is the timeline and what
the risk and the Fallout for the
security of the Middle East and hencefor
Europe will be yeah it
lets the people in Iran alone
report and just briefly what we heard in
the streets is this is not a protest
anymore this is the beginning of a
revolution one word yes
thank you so much to all of you for
being with us thank you out there for
tuning in and please send us your
comments on our topic we very much want
to hear from you dear audience so thanks
for joining us and see you soon
[Music]